- No.
(guitar notes trilling)
♪ Obsessions ♪
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] What is this?
- [Edgar] (laughing) Sleeping with thick
- [Kelly] I do this!
- fuzzy socks
I can't-
- Love it!
- If I'm not next to a body of water,
my feet needs to be covered.
- I'm sorry, wait, what?
(audience laughing)
- If I'm not in the water,
meaning, like, on the beach
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- or by a pool,
and my feet can't touch the water,
I need to cover my feet.
Like, my feet cannot be-
- You always wear socks.
- Always, I always wear socks.
- Oh, I thought you just meant
when you sleep
- So I cannot...
I sleep naked.
- Do you ever do this thing
where you get hot in the night, though,
and you have to kick 'em off?
- But the-
- Like in the middle of the night,
do you get hot
- No, never, never.
- [Kelly] and then you kick 'em off,
and then I put 'em back on the morning?
- No, I kick off the blanket,
- Yeah.
- but never the socks, yeah.
- Oh!
- The socks stays on, yeah.
- See I keep the blanket,
kick off the socks,
and then I put them back on in the morning
'cause I'm cold.
- Yeah.
- We're weird.
- Yeah, I mean, I...
yeah.
- You should-
- Yeah, I mean,
I was just thinking
that I do clip my toenails.
- Yeah? - [Edgar] You
know, so it's not about
- Well, good for you.
- It's not about like
hiding my feet, you know?
I mean, it's not like, I'm like,
- [Kelly] They're not gnarly.
- You know, and like, my
dad was in the military,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- so you know like
clean nails are important, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- And polished suit.
- I'm like trying to hide mine right now.
I'm like, I don't know what
mine look like right now.
But yeah, mine always stay clean too.
I'm hiding them, yeah.
Well, look, they're
- They're beautiful.
- just very basic.
- Oh, no, they're great.
- They're like, whatever.
Okay, last one, this is Edgar's, go ahead.
(button clicks)
(note trills, gentle music plays)
♪ Obsessions ♪
(bell dinging)
What is this?
(Edgar laughs)
Winter hats shaped like animals?
- I mean, you gotta have some fun, right?
- Wait, what?
- So well, it's, I just
like winter hats with like,
animal shape, like, with funny...
funny I guess, you know?
- [Kelly] Like a actual- oh!
- [Edgar] There you go, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes, and you look
like you're having a good time, yeah.
- I was.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Well, you know what?
That's, um, pictures do lie.
I was having such a bad time.
I was so sick when I took that picture.
- Oh.
- So sick.
And I was having tea.
I was having this Argentinian
or Hawaiian mate tea.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, for the Argentinians,
for the people in the audience.
- [Kelly] Is that really good
for you when you're sick?
- It's really good when you're sick.
It's good for everything, which is
- [Kelly] I wanna know this secret.
- Yeah, it's really good
And I was wearing, yeah, my...
how do you call that frog?
- The frog, yeah?
- Caramel, Caramel, yeah?
- [Staff Member] Kermit.
- Kermit, Kermit.
- We're gonna call him Carmel though.
- Carmel, you see,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
the accent?
- Yeah, I love it, I love it.
Okay, those are our
(musical notes chime)
♪ Obsessions ♪
(audience cheers, claps)
Be sure to watch Edgar's show, Dr. Death.
It's on Peacock now.